I didn't go red mani remember
welcome to Cemetery dreams it's been a
while since I am ladies game so I
thought it could be pretty cool to play
this game a lot Ebro suggested it it's
basically a pretty drunk game
you versus computer I think I'm the
white one no I'm the blue one look at
this tap that all right bro we can
settle this I don't know you touch me I
kill you I kill you bet
oh no I should have won that one oh here
we go
you better not touch me really if you
touched me bro
come on quit me bro come at me bro
Kleber off all right you got me two out
of one but it's first two three [ __ ]
but hey push man push me imma like see
if I can get out of this position I do
you better not ah that's what you get
you little bit don't kick me Jesus
Christ don't kick me about you hey my
butt move ah [ __ ]
god damn I shouldn't have so many
[ __ ] margarita all right Rock braaap
braap brother
I'm not even particularly big I know and
you like bushings shits don't don't fall
down what what the hell are you doing
bro
alright let me turn around I'll kill you
for this bruh kill you after I [ __ ] god
damn it
doc doc ah trying to get up here woo I'm
up all right here we go don't rape me
please don't oh you missed me haha
stay down mother F whoa alright
backspace oh these are thinking I'm so
stupid I bruh
alright bro we can satellite over Allah
Allah hey what are you doing back off
[ __ ] back off and the king of this
jungle
don't [ __ ] ah
damn I'm the blue one by the way in case
you didn't realize tap that all right
come at me bro my bra come on bro come
at bra now I never win this all right
seriously now try it babe my bro
that's right [ __ ] hahahaha
let's cut out oh yeah hi LA why not
cuddle like a lab rat come on bro
alright [ __ ] yay that's how I Broward
that's how I get all the ladies victory
dance victory dance victory dance
victory - ah [ __ ] this is what happens
when I dance what hell is doing no I try
to get up god damn
alright let's play this with like arena
selection kitchen party with like more
players for computer no wait
second am I playing this yeah no yes yes
no and I believe what the hell are we
doing
wait a second you and oh ok ok I wasn't
playing and drunk like these people all
right miss anyone touching me - I'll
kill you
what Elliot I didn't do it I have a
brown one come here bro remember ah come
on ah [ __ ] you up [ __ ] I care yeah
you kiss my girlfriend Raquel yeah so to
get gonna stare at you stead of that ass
hell are you doing what are you doing
malroux
oh here we go here we go god damn it oh
I won that one
how do we really all right [ __ ] mouth
anyway all right let's all join the
table cavity ah [ __ ] I want to [ __ ]
that's another man actually let's do I
have a lot of Mac's download by the way
a seesaw what's seesaw I shaved by the
way I miss my bail or beer two computers
son right you and Erica oh yeah ha I
have this ass what the hell are you
doing
push your [ __ ] that's right
ah god damn it second place
come on now I'll just stay here you're
not gonna lose this what yeah what soda
possible I have that ass what what what
push you how is it possible oh I [ __ ]
you up
what did you do it the Brahma this
[ __ ] game alright bras come in grab a
bra alright let's team up on the white
one [ __ ] killed ah goddamn it
diamond get off me all right here we go
here we go here we go
come on brah come on brah you wanna it's
like a cat fight or with drunk people
drunk cat fight is it what is it brown
brown one is [ __ ] crazy
goddamn there we go alright I'll see you
in a second because I want to try out
the downloadable mats they're pretty
cool all right
ha ha bring it [ __ ] come on come here
bro
[ __ ] all I'm saying it No ah god damn it
always gonna fall he's gonna bomb son of
a [ __ ]
sign about does it stop ah ah god damn
i'ma die not really what the yellow one
I mean what yellow one really how does
he doing up there keep hearing a lot of
fun doing come on brah get up let's do
that I would like for people what I shot
quit written in quake stupid all right
let's all meet in the center I'm gonna
get the white one [ __ ] everyone teamed
up on the white one I know that's a long
path so what still up there
ah I'm alive the green one is in trouble
don't care the brown one is going down
coming for you [ __ ]
ah wait a second wait I want to show
this by the way it's pretty cool if you
shoot that block I don't know why no oh
this map you can pretty much [ __ ] this
guy up it's like the best [ __ ]
irena selection can I do that here about
kitchen party I'll [ __ ] him up
I think I'll work though come on man
there we go yeah all right hey bruh how
you done I'm goddamn it stop it stop -
ah goddamnit
right in the butt keep shooting the but
poor guy I feel bad for him it's pretty
good like stress relief or whatever like
you want to take out your anger on a
little poor rag doll right in the boat
it's beautiful
make it stick there fits there pretty
nice what is he doing like I give up not
have I just take me take me now ah [ __ ]
of my life
[ __ ] I would I did it to serve I'm not
in the faith ah [ __ ] ah I'm not giving
up though not how you can do it so I
gotta you can do this all I don't get it
can get such high up [ __ ] out I'm done
by barn oh it's stuck there right yeah
actually kind of like it
oh yeah good yeah yeah I came I came
again oh maybe is it coming yes it came
again
da [ __ ] yeah good wait to stick oh my
god oh my god oh my god pity what the
hell is all right that is out what down
ah
oh wow epic backflip take it I'm taking
it just good I like it alright damn Jew
go yeah later [ __ ] no
uh hi mr. [ __ ] happy [ __ ] uh I don't
mean tonight all right
and let's do one other how about I go
downstairs with people all right
oh [ __ ] that brown one has got his eyes
on me
[ __ ] off bro [ __ ] off you're a [ __ ] when
they are yeah dammit - like I don't get
if you're supposed to alright let's see
if I can get out of this situation go
for the widening gap into our app so
Haley's yeah I gotta win one of these
it's [ __ ] impossible right here we
get back up yes
you just got to prolong the [ __ ] oh
man he wants Cadiz I'll just stay here
I'll leave I could wash it Saleh but
anyway I think I left her there um it's
a pretty cool game I'll leave your
download link
I think I don't know if you pay for it
or not I just had it on my computer I
don't remember but anyway like it fit if
you enjoyed this kind of combo today and
I'll see you next episode of when I
roaming stay awesome earth that wanna
cook with him
this game is not scary they said play
this game hey how you done
I like what you did a fool